okay the time has come to wrap up
transactions where we will cover
transaction rules and the two things we
will start with our snapshot isolation
which defines the read consistency and
optimistic concurrency which governs
concurrent updates we'll start off with
snapshot isolation and please observe
that this behavior may differ between
languages so be sure to check out the
documentation the first rule is that all
read operations in a transaction will
return the values data store had when
the transaction started and the second
rule for snapshot isolation is updates
will not be reflected while in the
transaction so if an entity is modified
or deleted in the transaction a query
will get the original version of the
entity or nothing if the entity did not
exist then that snapshot isolation but
please be sure to check out the
documentation as this behavior somewhat
language specific so let's turn to
optimistic concurrency this rule is that
a commit transaction will only be
successful if the values updated by this
transaction have not changed since the
begin transaction if the values that you
are trying to update has changed since
begin the transaction will fail then
there are two additional rules you
should be aware of the first is that one
transaction can modify at most five
ancestor groups the second rule is that
a transaction must complete within 60
seconds but the general rule is of
course to keep the execution of
transactions short as short as possible
unless in extremely rare cases it should
be finished within a couple of seconds
and in most cases less than a second
that completes this section